yes this is just a tutorial on how to
get Skype it's not about it's not
actually a real on skype yet but this is
an actual just how to and where to get
it so I open up my internet browser and
I'll go to google.com and just type in
Skype and the first result will be Skype
comm on it and it take you to the Skype
comm website right there is where you
download it for Windows um I haven't
tried it on the Mac Pro but I will
eventually this is basically all about
Skype PC PC calls free video calls if
you have a webcam um click here to
download it click here another tab on
skype comm to figure out basically how
you begin to Skype Skype phones finding
friends when you're done doing it from
the Downloads tab it will be up you will
have the program and obviously you can
figure out if you have it or not if you
have Windows Vista just type in Skype
and there you get a program I have it
right here
rocketdock so I click type takes a
second to load and then it has a little
animation and a sound
there's your sound and we are in so
Skype I know it works in Windows Vista
32-bit it will not work in a 64-bit
Vista also the cool thing is that if
you're just if you're browsing the web
you're just you know an hour fox
something and you you pull up this thing
on a bot you can call that company in
Skype I've called Best Buy and staples
recently just looking asking fat
products which is a little faster I
guess then you know staples that name is
spell it right so it's just Skype is a
little bit faster than actually going
and looking and going to the store etc
there's a lot of stores I've bought
things from that I didn't even know had
what I wanted until I open Skype and
call them up and they told me clear what
they have
so there's your tutorial on how to
acquire the Skype program here is a
system tray um
so yeah good luck downloading and leave
your comments and I'll get back to you
on how to use it thanks for watching
guys